YURI GRINSHTEYN: Are
you a developer who runs
workloads on Kubernetes or GKE?
Well, if you are, then
you're probably familiar
with Prometheus, the de facto
standard for open source
monitoring on Kubernetes.
And you probably know that
managing Prometheus at scale
can be a real big
challenge sometimes.
My name is Yuri.
I'm an SRE at Google Cloud.
And today, I'm going to show
you how to use Google's Managed
Service for Prometheus
to monitor your GKE
workloads without having
to manually manage
Prometheus at scale.
This is engineering
for reliability.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The first thing to
understand is the nature
of the service itself.
This is Google Cloud's
fully Managed Service
for Prometheus metrics.
It's built on top of Monarch,
the same globally-scalable data
store as Cloud monitoring.
You can replace your existing
Prometheus deployment
to collect cluster
and workload metrics
and then query the data across
multiple clusters using PromQL.
Sounds intriguing?
I'm so glad.
Let's have a look at
how you can get started.
Let's start by validating our
existing Prometheus deployment.
Here, we can see that we have
all of the necessary components
running.
This includes the
Prometheus server itself;
the node exporter, which
collects infrastructure metrics
from our cluster nodes;
and the Grafana UI.
Next, let's make sure that
metric collection is working.
We can connect to the Prometheus
server UI using port forwarding
and run a query to confirm that
metrics are being collected
and that we're
able to query them.
At this point, we're ready
to migrate this installation
to send metrics to the
Managed Prometheus Service.
The Prometheus operator is using
a Prometheus custom resource
to manage these components.
We can edit it
and simply replace
the images using with
Google's forked version
of the Prometheus server.
This binary is configured
to scrape both workload
metrics and its own
metrics endpoint
and send the collected data to
the Managed Service backend.
Once we confirm that the
server has restarted,
let's again validate
local metric collection
and querying using
port forwarding.
Everything still
works as expected.
But now, we can go
to the Cloud console
and run our query there.
This confirms that these metrics
are being ingested properly.
We can also query the
same metrics using
Metrics Explorer, for
example, and use them
to create charts or alerts.
So if you're already running
Prometheus in your GKE cluster,
you can easily migrate to the
Google Cloud Managed Service
for Prometheus and
ingest your metrics
into Cloud monitoring just
by replacing the Prometheus
binary.
It's just that easy.
Thanks so much for
watching today.
We learned how Google's
Managed Service for Prometheus
allows you to monitor your
clusters without having
to manage Prometheus
manually, how
to migrate your existing
Prometheus setup,
and how to use PromQL
to query the data.
Next time, we'll instrument
our own application
and configure Prometheus
monitoring for it.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
See you soon.